et bien s'il est une chose qui vous a
marqué cette année du point de vue météo
ce sont les températures anormalement
chaudes cet été et plusieurs canicule
qui ont touché non seulement le canada
mais la planète entière
et ça c'est sans oublier bien sûr cette
vague de froid intense qu'on a connus au
début du mois de janvier 2018 peut-être
vous en rappeler d'ailleurs
tour d'horizon en maintenant des points
marquants de l'année avec alexandre
parent il est météorologue à
environnement et changement climatique
canada
il nous fait le plaisir d'être avec nous
ce matin en direct d'abord on va y aller
avec ce qui nous touche le plus c'est à
dire les prévisions là pour la fin de
semaine le 31 et pour le 1er janvier
2019 oui et même pour la la la semaine à
venir comme mentionné pour le week-end
qui approchent donc plusieurs
avertissements plus glaçante à travers
le québec principalement le sud l'ouest
et le centre de la province d'être là
devraient débuter fin nuit tour demain
matin pour la région de montréal
plus tard en mi journée voire en après
midi pour la région de québec
donc ceux qui ont des déplacements à
faire pour la journée de demain
c'est vraiment consulter peut-être de
suivre l'évolution des différentes
prévisions et ceux par exemple qui ont
un choix à faire entre la rive-sud et la
rive-nord entre l'a20 ou l'a40 peut-être
de prendre la main avec une bonne option
demain on s'attend à une période
prolongée vraiment du côté nord du
fleuve saint laurent en termes de pluies
verglaçantes et par la suite on va
passer à la pluie et même samedi les
conditions pour être parfois difficile
par endroits on pourrait être à plus 3 +
5 degrés samedi matin mais le mercure
chutera gras rapidement durant la
journée de samedi
donc le tout pourrait reculer de façon
assez rapides donc c'est vraiment de
s'assurer de suivre l'évolution des
différentes prévisions pour les
différentes régions à mesure qu'on
s'approche de l'événement on est capable
de raffiné mais assurément que les deux
prochains jours ne sont pas les journée
idéale pour pour avoir des déplacements
faire et c'est vrai sur l'ensemble de la
province basque
maintenant revenons un peu en arrière
avec cette année 2018 qui a quand même
été assez particulière au niveau
climatique
qu'est ce qu'on retient en fait dans ce
fameux palmarès de records météo canada
principalement moscou ce qui marque
c'est vraiment le fait que la science
des changements climatiques nous
indiquent qu'il ya des relations à faire
avec les émissions
la hausse des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre par l'être humain et il ya
certains certaines conditions
météorologiques on est capable d'être
aussi par exemple ont aussi qu'avec le
réchauffement climatique les vagues de
chaleur vont être plus fréquents plus
intense on l'a connue avec l'été
estivale que partout sur l'ontario le
québec et même à l'échelle de l'europe
de l'asie également dont des
températures record pour cet été on a eu
des indices humidex atteignant les 47
voire 48 donc non encore la démarque
jamais établi et on est capable de faire
une relation avec justement la hausse du
gaz à effet de serre et des conditions
non plus des vagues de chaleur qui sont
plus intenses qui vont perdurer plus
longtemps comme on l'a connu cet été
également sur augmente le risque
d'inondation d'érosion côtière avec la
hausse du niveau de la mer
on a eu des conditions telles avec d une
tempête
par exemple au mois de janvier secteurs
de la gaspésie qui a été très affectée
mais également les inondations de la
rivière saint-jean au mois de mai donc
des accumulations
c'est un petit peu une combinaison qui
est arrivé au nouveau brunswick donc des
accumulations de neige tardives avec un
retour assez intense on a eu du 28 29
degrés au début mais alors qu'on avait
encore un bon couvert de neige
additionné à la pluie donc ces
conditions là on ne peut pas vraiment
les relier aux changements climatiques
mais on est capable de dire qu'ils vont
arriver de façon plus fréquente souvent
plus intense même chose avec les feux de
forêt mais c'est sa chaleur et
sécheresse justement ça va être fait un
cocktail explosif là dans l'ouest
canadien avec eux ces incendies assez
impressionnant oui alors si on fait un
top 10 on pourrait en faire une émission
vous aurez un petit top 3 à l'échelle du
québec
on en a déjà parlé la chaleur estivale
presque 100 morts causés directement par
cette chaleur donc des valeurs records
un mois de juillet ou combinés
pratiquement record sinon top 3 pour
pratiquement toutes les villes du québec
n'est peut-être en deuxième position
mais les tornades
la tornade d'ottawa gatineau on a même
dénombré six tornades pour cette journée
mais la plus marquante aura été la f3
donc des vents jusqu'à 260 km et une
tornade de f3 au québec on en observe
une environ aux 7,1 mais que ça traverse
une zone densément peuplée
ça c'est très très rare donc on a eu
une multitude d'image sur les réseaux
sociaux goûts et pour avoir été là
vraiment le lendemain matin aux petites
heures cette exceptionnelle dans le
secteur mont bleu secteur dans le noir
but dans l'est ontarien qui ait pas eu
de décès associés vraiment avec ce
passage cette tornade est peut-être en
troisième position pour ce qui est de la
province de québec
un mois d'avril très froid le plus froid
depuis 71 ans vraiment pour l'est
ontarien et le sud du québec une période
prolongée de verglas également un
verglas le plus tardif jamais observé à
montréal d'une durée qui a pratiquement
atteint une vingtaine d'heures donc
c'est un petit peu moins le top 3 que je
peux faire pour ce qui est de la
province de québec
ok maintenant on le voit le climat
continue de se modifier il évolue est ce
que ça veut dire que dans le fond il
faut mieux se préparer à ces conditions
météo parfois extrêmes il faut être de
plus en plus vigilants oui parce que le
changement climatique parfois on le voit
peut-être comme un gros monstre qui va
arriver de façon assez soudaine mais
c'est pas comme ça que ça se produit
télé le petit à petit d'un petit peu la
la la grenouille dans la marmite donc
l'eau la température augmente petit à
petit la fréquence des épisodes de
sécheresse de conditions propices aux
feux de forêt voire d'inondation des
vagues de chaleur jusqu'à elles sont
plus fréquentes de façon plus intense
également
donc oui les villes et même les citoyens
on doit faire une note paraît également
avoir sondé des des plans pour si on va
avoir une trousse de 72 heures par
exemple ces c'est ce qui est recommandée
en cas de panne d'électricité qui
pourraient être dues par causés par des
tornades ou encore des inondations donc
ces genres de choses qu'il faut à
l'échelle humaine
un citoyenne s'assurer de faire en
prévision justement des prochaines
années donc un petit tour sur le site
internet de environnement et changement
climatique canada ne devrait pas faire
de tort justement alexandre métérologue
merci beaucoup d'être venu ce matin